l'enquêté à vous suivez pour arte france
cette audience où en sont les échanges
alors l'audience a repris après une
suspension c'est françois fillon qui est
à la barre qui s'explique depuis
maintenant un très long moment il tente
de garder son calme très vivement
attaquée par les procureurs il a par
exemple dit soit je ne suis pas assez
clair soit vous avez des problèmes de
compréhension à l'adresse du procureur
donc vous voyez un petit peu l'ambiance
ici alors au fil des témoignages qui ont
été lus par la présidente il est
toujours très difficile de caractériser
l'activité de pénélope fillon que
faisait-elle exactement et bien c'est
l'objet des discussions aujourd'hui
françois fillon a de toute manière
indiqué que les archives étaient
détruites après chaque législature donc
on ne retrouvera pas de trace écrite
il ne faut se fier qu'aux témoins alors
justement les témoins bien tout à
l'heure on a appris que les assistants
parlementaires ont expliqué que pénélope
fillon était chargé de trier du courrier
des habitants de la sarthe et de donner
des directives problème c'est que il
n'apparaît pas très clair que les
directives abouti c'est bien en bout de
chaîne à la personne chargée de s'en
occuper
et puis les préfets par exemple ou bien
dit que pénélope fillon assisté à des
événements à des inaugurations mais
qu'elle ne les a jamais sollicité en
dehors de ces événements et puis qu'ils
ignoraient qu'elle était rémunéré en
tant qu'assistante parlementaire
rémunérer justement notamment pour cette
présence alors françois fillon a bien
fait valoir à de nombreuses reprises un
travail de proximité avec les habitants
donc il ya ce cet éventuel tri de
courrier et puis cette présence aux
événements alors est-ce qu'il faut être
rémunéré pour cela c'est la question et
et françois fillon a d'ailleurs rappelé
que toutes les épouses d'élus ne sont
pas systématiquement la aux événements
loin s'en faut certains ne jouent aucun
rôle politique est là a minima en tout
cas pénélope fillon assisté tout de même
a quand même produit que quelques
missions auprès de son mari
ça ça a l'air
c'est entendu mais c'est alors que le
des procureurs a donné la question à
poser cette question centrale est ce
qu'il ya une corrélation entre la
rémunération qui était très importante
et la consistance du travail donc ça va
être continuée pardon être examiné au
fil de l'audience et on vous tiendra au
courant ici devant la trente deuxième
chambre
merci beaucoup gâté un pique-niqué à
tout à l'heure